o dia em que eu fui para Irlanda de um
jato muito raio aqui eu perguntando se
tinha que tirar o tênis para entrar se
tem gente que faz isso numa casa velha é
Quem dirá no bichão desse
curiosidade sobre mim eu só ando
encostando nas coisas para saber a
consistência sabe se é bom se presta né
aqui ela tá toda solta Curtindo esse
tinha bebido era uma moça disse que
tinham 30 anos bebida mais velha que eu
eu já fui bebendo e nem saber se tava
podre como diz o ditado quero nem saber
quem foi que morreu eu quero é chorar
ouro de graça meu filho Ai suquinho de
Urucu já patrocinador deixou até uma
coberta para o pivete Por isso que eu
digo meu filho ou não esse amigo de quem
tem
[Música]
aqui eu chegando na Irlanda mamado
Acordei hidratei já fui treinar eu não
vim aqui para choromélia que eu não vim
aqui para churumela Diegão já puxando a
manopla
lembrando dia 15 de julho eu luto aqui
na Irlanda